wire it is basically a dayglo executive
summary by a scout who is reporting back
from this new territory west of
california called the future starting at
magazine it's like her like starting a
restaurant it's a really good recipe for
failure very few restaurants that really
work or make money and there's very few
magazines that never work so my first
impression of Wired was that it's
another magazine is going to fail the
moment that I change my mind about that
was when Luis summarize the the mandate
and he said that what he wanted to do is
to make a magazine that appeared as if
it had been mailed from the future I ran
a magazine and I reviewed a magazine
that Lewis and Jane worked on Cold
language translation it was the magazine
about using computers to translate
languages in a very small circulation in
Holland but it was very interesting
because it wanted to be bigger Louis and
Jane said they were going to make a real
magazine about computers that wasn't
boring and they had the exact recipe for
Wired which was big idea real people
marry it into conical of our times
we're magazine is explosion of ideas and
pictures and people and exciting
developments that's delivered every
month I said well you need to move to
San Francisco because that's where it's
happening Wired magazine was primarily a
magazine that we were writing for
ourselves and we knew that what we were
talking about an interested in would be
what everybody else would be interested
later on the stories that we were
running were about how technology impact
in society and how it might change our
behavior fund the very beginning wired
believes in the digital platform as a
publishing platform and fund the very
beginning believe that the web would be
a commercial medium that would run on
advertising and from the very beginning
wire believed in search so we had when
the first search alternative search
engines to AltaVista long before Google
wired was kind of a co-inventor of the
click-through ad banner and I believe
that that had wired not been divided and
sold that we might have actually arrived
to the same place at Google head wired
is still relevant because it's a
magazine about the culture of technology
and there's nothing else that's talking
about it at that level but actually the
surprising thing to me is how still
vital and unique wire it is because it's
talking about the consequences of
Technology
you